hi so I'm going to talk about how to
compute the edge connectivity of a graph
deterministically kneeling that time so
we're basically dealing with just simple
graphs so just classic graphs no
parallel edges we're just dealing with
the pairs of points and the edge
connectivity of such a graph is the
smallest number of edges whose removal
will disconnect the graph so in this
graph here we have we can just take out
two edges we're also more we're lot more
looking at the duel what the cut defined
by just a set of verses so this set of
virtues out here and it has two sides
the set of vertices and the compliment
and then we have the card edges that
connect these two sets and the basic
result is that now we can find the edge
connectivity including a minimum cut
deterministic in the linear time so this
is a very classic problem to deal with
has a lot of history so I'm just going
to have n vertices M edges the inch
connect to be lambda which is of course
at most the minimal degrees it's always
have the COTS achieve by taking out a
single vertex which again just by
averaging in most to M divided by n so
it goes all the way back to 61 that
comment who discovered that you can
solve the global min caught by n minus 1
minimum st cots you just take out a nap
trary sauce and then you it has to be on
one side and then you have to somehow
find a purchase on the other side which
could be any of the n minus 1 other
vertices and then you combine that with
your favorite esteeming corner of rhythm
so at the time they could combine with
both bulkers and you get this kind of
time pound which involves the size of
the cuts or you can combine it with the
later even and tartan algorithm also for
simple graphs like mine and you get this
time bound so it was not until 73 that
somebody came up with an algorithm what
that was better than just taking in
esteem in cots okay so that I can't
pronounce the name but anyhow he got
this kind of time bounce which was
rediscovered but I think it's because of
the language this thing was published in
anyhow
then it took another number of years
almost 20 years before anybody figured
out how to do it for weighted glass and
for multi-class this result here was for
simple crafts like mine and here the
same bound was found by us but these
were marginal results I have four take
directed graphs or simple Arkansas hold
very cool so one of the things that will
be more relevant to this talk or sort of
thing i will use is just that if we want
to MIT find out if a graph is cage
connected we can always restrict our
attention to k and edges and that's the
symbol outram we will just take a
spanning tree out of the graph and your
K times take a maximum spanning forest
out of the graph and the edges that you
have taken out they will have the same
cage connectivity or less than the graph
you started with okay so this is a very
standard thing then put but it could be
done in the near time even if K is large
then we have mature who showed that you
can do with 2 plus epsilon approximation
so two things together say that because
you could do this approximation and then
find lambda then you just set k equal to
2 to the that number that's another
pound and you can just use that number
here we can always find the graph which
has lambda and edges and the same edge
connectivity just original graph okay so
that's just an epic I will just think of
the rest of the ages as noise and I'll
pretend they're not there so that's what
I'm going to assume from now on
so some history that's more ready to
what I've been doing here is Cobble Hill
showed that you could find the global
men caught in lambda aim time so the
edge connectivity is lambda which could
be as large as in and we can actually
find the men caught in lambda times m
and he also has some slightly better
balance for multiplaza well so this was
for simple glass but it's only gets
slightly worse for multi graphs and
again when waiting whenever we talk
about lambda we're always just talking
about unweighted graph since the edge
connective is only defined for
unweighted glass and then kaka starts
doing all his wonderful full months of
Carlos stuff so there's a textbook
algorithm which just do this random edge
contraction it's absolutely beautiful a
lot of that algorithm and it gets down
to quadratic time the one together with
Stein and then he started improving on
on a cabos bound getting down to square
root lambda again it's Monte Carlo where
you have this problem that it comes with
the cuts but it can't guarantee it's the
smallest cards okay and there's no way
of guaranteeing that and then finally he
found the global min card in need a
linear time and it also works with
weighted graphs it was a really nice
breakthrough but as you said we have no
way of verifying that we actually have a
minimum cost if you want to be sure you
still have to run cabos algorithm and
the result of this paper is that we can
find the global min context mystically
for simple graphs in nearly net time and
there's a log 212 that I know looks ugly
but nevertheless just just how it is and
the funny thing is active chose this is
google and they actually interested in
implementing this so that as with many
things in theories don't work directly
but they're often many important
elements in the theoretical construction
that can be very relevant in practice
when you just want to do general
clustering of brass and stuff like that
but this is a purely pure theory talk so
the underlying result is well first i
define a trivial cut as one that just
takes out a single vertex ok these are
sort of the boring ones and then a
non-trivial one is one like this one and
the basic result is that you have a
cymol simple graph with minimal degree D
Delta then nearly enough time we can
contract somewhere
just producing a graph with Delta fewer
edges for serving all non-trivial min
cut so for a graph like this one we can
do these contractions here right so it's
okay to destroy a trivial cut but we
cannot destroy any non-trivial [ __ ] and
yet we get a graph with much for your
edges this look a little bit like
specification very that's not the new
graph will typically be denser because
we're contracting edges so we are
getting fewer Burgesses so why is this
not for multi-class well it clearly
can't be just take a cycle like this one
a full cycle or any cycle right where we
just put parallel edges then any of
these cuts see of which there's a
quadratic number here will actually be a
non-trivial min cuts according to the
definition I would say well what about
without the parallel edges then
everything every edge is in a non
trillion cut that's true but I'm not
guaranteeing anything here right because
I only want to divide by the minimal
degrees if you look at a cycle the
minimal degree is 2 and tilta m divided
by 2 is probably going to be more than m
and not less okay so it's only when the
degree gets large that this thing here
becomes interesting and if the degree is
small then because lambda small then we
can just run Garbo's algorithms so i can
assume that the degrees a large okay
so when I first have this thing then
we're done then i can just ran run gabos
min cut or cactus algorithm on on this
contracted graph if you don't know what
cactuses forget about it it's just a
very nice way of representing all men
cuts and we can do that as well because
again it runs in lambda the edge
connectivity is still going to be at
least the same or roughly the same and
on em and because m is so much smaller
it becomes linear all we have to do at
the end is to check against Delta to see
if two real money is some of the trivial
men cuts actually small loss should be
included okay and then we get everything
in nearly near time so how do we get
this kind of result I'm actually going
to work with a cut conductance so while
your mother set up versus is just the
number of edge endpoints in the sets
okay make sounds funny call volume but
there will be reasons for that later
okay and then the edges leaving the set
I just denote with this usual notation
the boundary notation here and so the
conductance of the cut well in its in
the case where you is not too large is
less than half the vertices then it's
just the number of virtual edges leaving
you divided by the number of endpoints
of Ages in you okay and then you just
have the symmetric then you have to look
at the small side so in case you try to
look at the big side then we just look
at the symmetric other side so that
means that the conductance of the cut is
of one set is the same as the
conductance of the compliment okay this
is just the definition but it's a
standard thing it's a thing that relates
to edge expansion so when you don't have
edge expansion it's because you have
this low conductance cards so just as an
example for trivial cuts they expand the
conductance is always one right because
every single edge leaves the set because
it's a single tone vertex if it's bigger
and you have some edges hiding inside
then you obviously get a smaller
conductance so in this case it should be
one-fourth so these are the non trivial
cots and those are the ones i find
interesting again the whole thing with
min caught all these things you get by
taking out a single vertex that trivial
what you're really worried about is if
there's some minimum caught hiding
inside the graph with lots of things on
both sides they are the ones that are
hard
to find and they are the ones we're
careful here so one relation between the
two things is that if you have a
non-trivial min cuts then it has
conductance at most 1 divided by the
minimum degree and again we assume the
minimum degree is large but large it
just means a large poli lock it won't be
something like log to the six or
something like that and why is that well
the number of edges leaving s is at
least well for each vertex it has some
degree Delta and then how many edges can
stay inside s that's in most s minus one
right so we have that bound and so and
we also know that because the min cut
the number of edges leaving it is that
most Delta because that was the main
degree which is an upper bound of the
main cot and because the set has at
least as more than one versus it was
supposed to be non-trivial then we
conclude that s has to be at most at
least Delta okay so that means about
volume is at least l2 squared because
the men degree was delta so that means
that we have low conductance and from
now on again I am assuming that the
minimum degree is at least lock to the
60 I shall apply kappa so that's how we
say that all natural min cuts have local
taxes for sure so again that means if
you have perfect expansion you know that
there are no natural min cuts so the key
in this algorithm here will be a
separate seat well it's not quite going
to be this one this is a simplified
version of it but it says a nearly
nettesheim will either certify that all
men cuts of the graph a trivial or will
find a cut with low conductance it just
has to be less than 1 over log m and
again remember when we had this mini
card we had a conductance which was 1
divided by log 2 6 okay so this is a
very moderate target but just I want to
make clear that each of these things if
you just want to do it alone it's not
something we at least before this talk
you how to do deterministically because
the first one to say certify that all
cuts are trivial is actually the same as
certifying the edge connectivity which
is the thing we didn't know how to do
where we had to apply Garbo's thing
because you could just
take this graph you want to know if its
foliage connected well if it has a
purchase of degree 3 then it's not so
assume all degrees at least fall then
you put a k3 you just attach it to it
and now if this one has a non-trivial
min cut so here we have things you know
cuts us to real cause of size 3 so if
this one has a non-trivial min cut then
this thing is not forged connected
alright so it's a very simple reductions
you just to say that this thing is as
hard as certifying edge connectivity on
its own and there's our thing about
finding cuts with small conduct sense
well that's also not so easy at least
not the if you want to do pagerank
because you have to guess a good start
vertex and that's again randomized yeah
ok so now i'm going to describe the oil
out women and also i'm going to this is
actually the 30 version of what i
presented before there's also the
vanilla thing but it's not quite enough
because i can't actually assume that all
the verses have full degree i will be
recursion dark we're cursing down i'm
going to lose some edges and stuff like
that but i will at least make sure that
in what remains the minimum degree will
be two fifths of the original minimum
degree and also instead of taking out
worrying about trivial cards i will
worry about semi trivial cuts where you
can take out two vertices and not just
one and i'm still looking for this small
conductance ok so suppose I had such a
thing now I want to show what the
all-out groom would look like just to
sort of justify why this certifier
justified but why certifying cart is
really an important sub for team so one
of these things will again be that if
you have certified a component in that
way so that it doesn't have this thing
then I will be able to contract large
parts of it I don't want to exploit that
because my whole goal is to certify
contract edges to create a much a graph
with much fewer edges ok so I start by
setting I have this variable graph H and
I start setting it to G and then I'm
looking around for some component that I
have not set a certified right but I
haven't certified this condition here
and then I apply this certify cut to one
of these components and I get certified
and I'm done with it oh I get a low
conductance cards right because that's
what I guarantee that would do one of
these two things and now I take all
these cottages in this local dachshunds
cut and remove them and also take away
all birds that have you lost too many
edges and I just keep this processor
when the while loop is done everything
has been certified and then I contract
something I call the cause which have a
lot of edges inside each of these
components the most important thing here
is note that I'm taking whenever I take
out whenever I find a low conductance
caught I take the edges out that means
that these are the edges i will not
contract right so I'm sort of working
the opposite way around i'm finding
these low conductance cuts and i say oh
that could involve something from a
non-trivial min cut so better not touch
these edges right so the end of the day
when I contract things I know that they
are not part of no conduction Scott
which means that they could not be part
of non-trivial min cuts if it wasn't
because I changed the graph a lot in the
process that's what makes it complicated
but let's just see that most atheists
remains after this process is done I
mean that's one of the critical things
because one thing is to say ayo these
edges look really dangerous these could
really be interesting a better not
contract and if end up saying that about
every edge in the graph I've gained
absolutely nothing so how can I be sure
that I don't contract too many well
that's something we use all the time
when you remove a low conductance cut
you charge the card edges to the edges
in the smaller side and each edge can
end in smaller side or logarithmic
number of times and because the
conductance was little o of 1 or login
so that means this is a charge you get
on each edge then you can't end up
charging the edges too much you conclude
that most of the edges will still remain
okay so so that's it so we have this
process we find all these edges that
could be relevant for some men caught
non-trivial men cuts and we just don't
touch them put them aside and we keep
going that way and now we only have
these edges we can safely contract and
we know that's a vast majority of the
edges so this is really good news now
you just want to recurse but when you
recurse you contract and you create
parallel edges and then everything I've
told you doesn't work in general but it
turns out that you don't create too many
parallel edges and somehow things still
work out nicely and after enough
recursions the analysis shows that you
get down to M divided by Delta HS and of
course there many details in this
how do you do that in linear time
because it's not obvious they even if
like the certifier cut algorithm is
linear know so that's so so this is what
I'm going to focus on doing in this top
here this is a critical one so i should
say i want to certify cart i wanted to
work in nearly a time that's what's
going to make it exciting because if it
used a lot longer time it wouldn't be
any good why is the whole recursive
thing well cuz you're so you don't
necessarily like it a balance that a big
round that is indeed true should be well
so I haven't said enough so yeah I'm
really sort of deicing a little bit here
so the maze painting point here is that
this outcome will be so efficient that
if it finds a small cut it will only
spend time proportions to a small
component that's a critical thing so
it's a very good point so yeah I've put
some things on say but at least I want
to present and correct algorithm but if
you want and just argue that most of
things remain so this is a method to
identify contractible edges and for the
efficiency you also need that it's
actually really efficient around that it
that it only pays for the small side of
the cards so very good point so now we
even establish more things about this
general Outram so i'm now going to
return to the toy problem where i'm
actually trying to certify that all men
cuts are trivial not just the symmetry
not all the same I trivial ones which
took out two birches but but that all
men coats of the form will just take out
a single vertex okay I want to fire all
I want to find the code of low
conductors and we recall that these are
both difficult on their own so we're
going to use page rank in the version of
Anderson and Chum and lund to emulate a
random walk so more normally page rank
is a Monte Carlo randomized algorithm
because it needs to guess as good start
but is to find that low conductance
codes
but we only need success if the first
point is false right we only need to
find the local duct and Scott if some
non-trivial min card exists which was
these things that we knew had very low
conductance and some other nice
properties and this gives us enough
structure to get a deterministic
algorithm by passing this whole need of
guessing so to present it I have to talk
a little bit about Anderson Chun and LAN
but it's absolutely beautiful stuff and
I like to talk about and also nice to
talk about other people's work because
then you can sort of be openly excited
about it and we're having some initial
mass distribution think of it
probability distribution so we just put
mass on the vertices and the total mass
is one so this is all just representing
where random walk would be but this is
actually the starting distribution and
then we have some strange names we have
a teleportation constant alpha and a
slack epsilon so when the whole thing
start we're always going to work with
some residual mass distribution and
originally that is just the initial
distribution and then we're going to
settle some of the mass but when we
start we haven't settled anything the
word settled this mind yeah so the
outcome works non deterministically why
there's a vertex which has too much
residual density right so this was the
reset your mass and we divided by the
degree and I don't know if you recall i
called degree volume so that's why it
becomes density and as long as there's
some vertex that has too much research
of tangency we do a so-called push and I
first I want to show you the picture so
we have some residual readies for
residual mass on a bear attacks and when
we do a push it's like hitting it with a
hammer right so you hit it down and most
of its splat us to the sides and this is
a very nice precise hammer splatters
exactly evenly on all the neighbors and
some of it you manage to really hammer
so that much down that it got completely
firm and will not move again right and
it froze it became blue okay and this is
just describing this formally right so
we take an alpha fraction of the
residual mass and knock it down at the
bear
text to settle it and then we take the
rest and distribute it evenly okay so
it's a very simple algorithm and you
keep doing it right until we have to not
have too much residual density anywhere
and then you just order the burgesses by
decreasing density and then you find the
best card defined by any prefix so you
have any threshold for density whatever
it might be and everybody who has
settled mass above that density there
one side of the card and everybody who
is below that threshold there on the
other side okay so you only have a
linear number of cuts to look through
and you can do that in not too much time
and what if the really nice thing is you
just look at the definition because
every time you do a push and send things
over the edges you also settle something
and we you know you're going to settle a
certain amount because we have this
epsilon here it actually follows that
the total number of edges you push over
is order 1 divided by alpha epsilon so
no matter how large the original graph
is it totally doesn't matter you still
have a nice cuppa dettori bound on I
don't know if you call a combinatorial
it's not like i'm not using matrix
multiplication anything like that but
you know you just have a precise simple
to stay bound on how many h's you end up
sending mass over and you only have to
spend constant time for each of these
pushes or one edge thing gained doesn't
land had an extra log factor but it's
unnecessary so it's a simple algorithm
we know it's fast and the only question
is when can we promise anything about it
because maybe it's just useless right
when do we know we get a low conductance
cot and to talk about that we actually
need to understand this page rank a
little bit better so the output we have
described is very efficient simple to
describe but if you want to understand
anything we have to keep just hammering
until there's nothing left which means
hammering infinitely many times we're
not going to do it but we can talk about
it then limit and basically say what do
we get and the important thing is if you
have it to the limit so there's nothing
left then you always get the same unique
limit distribution
okay so it doesn't matter the order in
which you do these things norland way
they love it with exactly the same
result and it's in fact a linear
transformation and it's the one that
satisfies this equation and one more
thing we need to know about it is that
this and that's the typical thing for
random walks that you have a stationary
distribution that doesn't change when
you do all this hitting around not at
least in the limit if all the densities
are the same okay and this is all
staying that about random walks good so
then when we understand what the limit
distribution is we're not going to
compute it but it exists as a
mathematical measure then what Anderson
shown and lung proof was that if it
doesn't matter does it it totally
doesn't matter how you start with the
initial distribution is if you can find
a set where the limit distribution has a
constant larger settle mass then that it
should have by averaging then we can
find the low conductance cards so it's
kind of funny that the starting point
doesn't matter at all right so if you
get too much concentration anywhere then
you actually find a local doctor Scott
so something has stopped the mass from
spreading around and that is a low
conductance part card and you can find
one of them ok so again the total mass
is one and just again we have 2 m.h
endpoint so the total volume is 2m right
and we compare that with the volume of
the set ok so that's this 2m that seems
confusing but it's just because each H
is counted twice so what they did was
that they said well if we start putting
their if we have a low conductance cuts
and we start putting all the mass in a
single vertex so because i have a total
mass of one if i assign one to one
vertex it means there's nothing left for
the rest then and it's a random vertex
then we expect to find this
concentration
but that's again by guessing the right
start vertex and there may be some
vertices inside the cut which are really
unfortunate because they start off
sending a lot of mass suicide but here
we do not want to guess so what we're
going to prove is that if we have and if
s is not just a low conductance card but
a non-trivial min cut and we start with
putting a mass of one on any vertex
inside then we get this concentration
needed to apply this theory ok so it's
not just for random vertex is from
arbitrary vertex of course I don't know
the non-trivial min cut yet so this
seems useless but at least it's better
somehow I'm going to argue that and then
i have a new theorem that a thing is
interesting because it sounds like it's
a metric but it's much stronger so it's
saying if there's a single vertex it
ends up with less limit density than the
average for vertex or for the whole
graph then we also get a low conductance
card right so up here we needed to get
too much density in the limit by a
constant down here we only need to get
too little by one or two to them so
there's a much finer measure ok so it's
not just the symmetry thing it's much
stronger right and this is sort of
interesting that if you look at the
places that where the mass doesn't get
too then it's a much more precise thing
that's going on then you if you look at
mass getting stuck it's also natural
because we're allowed to heaven well in
these examples here the initial
distribution is putting all the mass on
a single vertex and when you do the
first hit with the hammer that birds get
at this proportional large settle mass
so in order to say something you really
need to argue that a lot of mass gets
stuck it has to be almost a constant it
can be a little bit less but that
doesn't matter then when you look at
where the mass doesn't go then you you
have a much tighter and stronger results
ok so just I want to just remind you of
this I'm just so proud of the picture
how do we do this pushing right so again
we take this red thing and we hit it
with the ham and it spreads out like
that and one of the simple ms is just
that if you have some starting
distribution it doesn't matter what it
is you just have to look at the settle
mass and every vertex then you can
easily see how much mass was pushed to
other bears tix right because every time
you send mass across the edge you settle
some mass and each end which is
proportional to the amount you send over
just kind of natural there just by
looking at the difference in densities
on the tooth on the two end points you
can say exactly how much flow cross that
particular edge ok and that's just
because this is the only way mass can
move around in the network ok so one of
the night sep consequences of lag that
is that if at some point now I'm here
with the residual mass I know that the
sum is less than 1 but it doesn't really
matter if you know that the residual
density of every vertex is below some
Sigma then from this point forward the
total flow or and any edge is at most
Sigma divided by alpha ok so we know
that we have and this is all of a kind
of nice thing so it says that when all
the residual densities are low enough
then not too much is happening in the
sense that there's not a single and no
single edge can carry too much flow of
course if you look at a lot of edges
they may carry a lot of flows but
there's no single edge carrying too much
flow from this point forward and that's
it can just exploiting that now the
residual densities are bounded by the
stationary distribution where all the
densities are Sigma and we know that
when we that when we start with one of
these fixed point distributions then
we're never going to settle more than we
start with so that means that there will
be no settlement beyond Sigma anywhere
and then we plug that into this lemma
here to get this bound on how much flow
can go away any edge ok so it's just
using the station of distribution
lemma okay so finally we get back to my
problem our problem here so we're going
to start from any birds in a small side
of a min cart and the goal is to after
that no matter which one it is we're
going to find them in cuts and now when
everything is a place is not so hard to
prove so we know we have a large minimum
degree and we said alfa-2b well some was
lit somewhat more than the inverse of
that number and then we look at a min
cart and actually this man card is only
it has to be at most a quarter of the
total volume so it's it's not close to
being balanced it is really a small min
cut with low batt not very small but at
most a quarter of the total volume and
then we take an arbitrary vertex and
push from it right because I promised it
would work no matter which vertex we
started from so let's do it okay so here
we knocked it with the hammer it
splattered out and I claim that the most
half the mass stays in s why is that
well it's basically because at least
half the neighbors are inside s because
if it is more neighbors outside s I
would move the vertex out and get a
smaller cuts and I assumed I had a
minimum cut right so it's also a nice
thing with no conductance cuts you can
still have some verses you can move back
and false but with many cuts we know
that every single vertex has to have at
least half its neighbors inside
otherwise we've made a mistake okay so
we have a bit more structure here so we
also know that at this point no vs has
too much research your mass right
because we split spread the mass out
evenly so it's a most 1 divided by Delta
so that also means the city of density
is at most 1 divided by delta squared
and that means that we now have this
bound on how much net flow can ever pass
over any edge which was 1 divided by
alpha delta square
but this we can now ask how much more
mass can leave this cut right so we know
how many h's can leave the cut that's at
most alpha which is at most Delta right
because it was a min cut and each of the
edges could carry at most 1 divided by
alpha delta squared so this means that
we have at most alpha lambda divided by
that number flow closing the car leaving
s and that's the lower bond flow so we
at the first in the first push we know
that after that at least half stayed
inside and then we just lose a little
bit more right and this is why I want
the original volume to be a quarter at
most a quarter because I have now proved
that almost half the mass stays inside
the original volume was only a porter so
that gives us this this density excess
which is least which is a constant close
to a half in fact a court reporter and
then ACL is guaranteed to find a low
conductance cut okay so so it's really
easy compared with the general low
conductance cut when we have these
trivial min cuts again I'm assume that I
could somehow find a virtuous inside a
non-trivial min caught and I assumed it
was not too big but let's just look at
the mole balance case that's really easy
how much time to have what we actually
time so there you just say that we're
now we're looking at a balanced min cut
which has between a quarter and three
quarter of the volume right and then we
say that has to be at most that can't be
16 purchases that incident to more than
Delta eight cottages right there's a
most Delta cottages and you have two end
points in each of them so we are
guaranteed that there so if you look at
16 verses one of them can't have too
many cartridges incident and now we just
look at 16 arbitrary vs. separately it
doesn't matter which one it is one has
most neighbors on the same side by sort
of a vast majority and then we do the
same argument as before okay so this
thing just says that it's very easy to
before with the min cut when it has
small volume we had to guess a vertex
inside
right but if there's any balance min cut
then it's totally trivial we just start
from 16 arbitrary burgesses we do our
pushing and we are guaranteed to find a
low conductance cut so we know that
there are no balanced non-trivial min
cuts so what about general non film in
cuts so we know we only have to look at
volumes which are less than a quarter
that is corresponding to em half and
suppose for some s we know that that we
only have to worry about finding a min
cut with volume at most s so again their
initial bounders em half and we're
actually in this process only going to
look for a non-trivial min cut which has
volume between us half and s so we sort
of have some pounds on what we're
looking for and then we of course going
to do that for small and small is so
what we do know that what's the first
thing we proved before was that if that
we can always take an arbitrary vertex
and then in time proportional to s I
haven't quite said that but that's true
we can find if we start with the birches
inside of some s prime which is a min
cut and has volume at less than s then
we will actually find it in this process
right so we have this opportunity before
that says take an arbitrary vertex we
can find out if it is in a small enough
min cut that's what we just saw before
so now we again just try a bunch of
these vertices and we pick sort of the
right number burgess to look at so the
critical numbers here it's M divided by
s and then there's some poorly locks and
because we said M divided by s and we
check each one in s time this is only
linear time we're spending on this okay
so let's assume that none of this
succeeds because otherwise we would be
done then all we have to do is to each
each of them an initial mass which is s
divided by M plus some junk
okay so we just spread the mass even
this all-new into it until this point
when we looked at the initial
distributions we always put all the mass
and a single vertex now we do something
different we have tested lots of
different vertices and we know that none
of them are in a non-trivial min cuts in
a small enough non-trivial min cut and
now we spread the birth now we spread
them ass evenly on all of them and we
apply page rank but again we know that
none of them have a density above this
simply because we spread the mass but we
got an extra Delta because that's the
degree and then we're basically done
right because we've spread the mass we
have an low density to start with a low
residual density and so that means that
the total a min cuts we know that no
mass starts inside the main card because
if this men cut is if we had a vertex
inside it would have been done in the
first rounds right so we know all the
mass starts outside this min caught s so
if we end up with any mass in here it
has to come be sent over the cottages
that most lambda H is going into s so
that means that the total flow that can
enter ass is at most length of time
alpha divided by M Delta so that becomes
less than s divided by 8 m but we assume
that the volume was at least as half so
so that means that the that the average
density in the set s is at most the flow
that can enter s from the outside / well
at least we can always divide by the
lower bound on the volume and that gives
1/4 m and the average density was
divided by 2 m and now we can apply the
new in games theorem for this page rank
thing okay so that's really the whole
thing so again the album would just look
for a non-trivial min cut it will use a
bunch of day don't bunch of different
verses as starting points and if it
doesn't find that they are inside a min
cut we know we have found a lot of
different verses which are not inside
main cuts so now I am looking from an in
cart from the perspective of a min cart
and I know that the mass is spread
nicely around outside and because it's
being spread enough I know that no age
can carry a lot of flow after this point
and since I have owned a few incoming
edges I know I can't get too much mass
no matter what and so that means that my
density will always stay below basically
half the average which means that we can
apply this theorem that says if you're
just a little bit off by a constant
factor for any single vertex on the
amount of density to end up with then we
can find a low conductance call around
you and the sort of nice thing here is
in some sense so we're finding a low
conductance cut here which we're
actually going to find one that
separates out all the guys who have no
wave low density so this car till here
what we have outside here will be on the
average half of each of these components
this is really good for our induction
because this means that what we somehow
be left will only be a quarter of these
things so the volume will be pushed down
so that's why this thing becomes really
efficient but for now we were just
looking at the Khoikhoi problem of
finding any low conductance cuts so we
are done here but we're actually doing
far more because we have guaranteed that
we have taken out most of these low
these vertices that are hard to reach
okay so this was sort of showing how we
could solve the toy problem which was
finding either a low conductance cut or
a or a non-trivial min cut and then I
make some claim about being able to
contract things and now I'll actually do
that for the real problem so it's still
same basic algorithm but I only all i
know is that i will have a component
where all all those have degree leads to
fifth and that there's no min cut that
splits out more than two Burgesses
because that's what i say i really need
and i'll just show you how to use that
so we say a vertex is loose if it has
less than half its half plus one of its
neighbors inside this component and all
other vertices in the coal so it's not a
recursive description it's just you take
every vertex and we want to say well
some of them may be loose and they lose
if they have too many neighbors outside
and if they have more than this number
of vertices inside they belong to the
core and then the basic limit is that we
can contract the core preserving all non
trivial mean cuts so why is that well
let's just look at an example right so
here is a here's the graph here's the
component so the component is all the
thing inside the black circle and the
dotted thing is sort of supposed to be
the call or what I go to argue is a call
and now we can consider some non-trivial
cuts aunt will mean cuts
of the original graph and it's
guaranteed that this Court takes out at
most two vertices B&W from from one side
right it can't take more than yeah so
that was the whole definition we had up
here so suppose that one of the birds
we've taken out was not loose right
because we guarantee we could contract
the cause so our warrior would be with
long as these vertices was part of the
call because then we're not allowed to
cut it away right I claim I can retract
the call so it better not and by
contracting the call I want to make sure
don't destroy any non-trivial min cut so
it better be that the call is completely
contained on one side of this
non-trivial min card otherwise i'm not
allowed to contract it right so if it's
not loose so if we have a problem where
this versus is part of the call then it
has at least its degree degree half plus
two neighbors inside see okay but at
most one of these neighbors can be
outside because we only took out two
vertices so that means that the vertex V
has at least TV habits degree plus 1
neighbors inside T on the side of the on
the call on the certified component so
that means that we will get for sure a
smaller card if we move B to the other
side so that contradicted it was a min
cut okay so it's a very simple argument
so the basic point is just from this
argument is that it's very easy to
identify a call inside one of these
certified components that can be safely
contracted and that was really here I
guess the last thing I want to say about
this algorithm so concluding remarks so
we presented a deterministic near linear
time algorithm to find edge connectivity
min card and cactus of a graph and what
was in some sense the nice thing about
it is that we identified this graph
where we contracted some edges where we
cut down so M divided by Delta edges and
still preserved all the non trivial min
cuts and then we could just apply
Garbo's algorithms black box without
even looking what's inside of them
because they've been made efficient now
and and in fact it's fairly straight
forward to further make sure we can
track down to a graph it's only till
torfinn edges so we can always get that
down to a few edges it's basically using
this trick of na kimochi baraka which
just said that we can assume the
original graph has at most n times
lambda edges and what we do what they do
in their witness is that they threw away
the remaining ages but you can also
contract all the remaining edges which
actually better thing to do then you
might even be able to recurse and do
something better so we get down to
having only all NHS and n divided by
Delta vertices and still preserving this
thing and in fact we can preserve all
cuts of at most 2 minus epsilon tile
societal original code so this thing
does not just work for min cuts it works
for approximately mean cuts ok so it's a
pretty powerful so we can do all this
contraction and preserve on all
approximately mean cuts so just one of
the nice consequences we know that the
number of min cuts or even cuts which
are min cuts within effects of two
there's only the number of these is the
most the quadratic in the number of
vertices that's what we say well known
stuff and now we know that for the min
cuts we get this bound and there at most
n trivial cuts so now we get this bound
on the number of these approximately
mean cuts the best of my knowledge
nobody knew that the number of min cots
decrease this way with the degree ok so
this is just a consequence for your math
not pure graph theory
of course my frustrations here that I
don't know what to do about multi class
and weighted graphs I mean as I say we I
could work with multi graphs will work
with multi graphs inside the algorithm
but it's because the limits to how many
parallel edges that can be and stuff
like that and it somehow should be
doable so it's very frustrating I don't
know how to do it another thing is I I
feel that this just this end game stuff
I think should be exploited more I mean
we have all these beautiful applications
of page rank and they always have this
sort of at least those I've seen this
tend to have this they use it there in
the beginning where they have this thing
that if we don't get stuck because
there's a low conductance cut that stops
us then we find a low conductance thing
and I'm sort of going the other way I'm
saying just take it to them and try to
spread out the mass and just keep
hammering until everything is done and
then you'll find all in some sense you
find all the dough conductors cuts and
one when I say all in one it's because
we can have a small no conductance cart
but if you put two of them together the
conductors not going to get any bigger
right so you can think of them as these
big parallel low conductance cuts and I
think this is a very powerful thing and
of course a really really big problem is
to do something similar for sth
connectivity right so the classic fault
focus and what does it do it finds it
just by bending pass it takes then have
time to find the on an augmenting path
so if you want to find the edge
connectivity between S&T you just run
the edge connectivity of mending plot
pass and that takes you they enter type
s lambda M times okay we've known how to
do this since 56 I think it's time to
improve it there has been some work of
[ __ ] and 11 showing that you can
actually specify this thing using
randomization which i think is really
cool so instead you get lambda times n
piss still surprising and nobody's been
able to beat this right we have better
bounds so length that could be large and
if lambda is large we have all these
cumbria problems people have in terms of
m and n but still nobody has a
fundamental improvement to ford focus on
sparse graph with low connectivity
between S&T so I think this is a
something we should really reconsider so
again yeah okay okay i'm basically done
sir okay two seconds wait wait okay so
we did have a linear time answers and
just again it's really cool with this
approximation so again we're asking if
our graph is safely connected against k
arbitrary edge cuts you have the
approximation answer which says perhaps
not put almost k half you're safe
against right this is to perception or
approximation kakaka again you ask if
you are safe and the answers again most
likely but perhaps not that's what you
get out of Monte Carlo and here we
actually saw all these kind of Wiggins
as they of course extremely interesting
but we prefer to get a sack
deterministic solution so that's what we
can do now and then I know I don't have
time for it but just for more fun
without rhythms comment to a peach dear
postal code making have one position
coming up next year but to Jesus